this is Jeff and this is Adam and we
love boobs just as much the next guy but
a gratuitous nip-slip in a video game
makes about as much sense as an hors
d'oeuvre platter at an orgy which is why
we decided to bring you the top 5 most
gratuitous boob shots in video game
number 5 Dante's Inferno
I knew Dante's Inferno was a total jug
fest when I got to Cleopatra
but basically spits out spider babies
from the nipples of four giant
undulating boobs all I'm saying is maybe
if the game designers spent half as much
time as they did rendering boobs wet as
they did on actual gameplay the game
wouldn't come out as like a bastardized
oversexed version of God of War I also
like the part where you find your wife
dead the sword sticking out of her and
as you go to kiss her and find out
what's going on that's just in your face
take that feminist movement number 4
Felicia from Darkstalkers see I have no
problem with fighting games with female
characters with big boobs dressed in
spandex but do we really need a Catwoman
dressed only in gauze bandage no that
was kind of gratuitous it's a glue Lou
Dallas from Fifth Element
if she was hot and not a cat number
three Leisure Suit Larry
summa [__] laude all right all the
Leisure Suit Larry games revolve around
sex but this one's especially bad they
basically use sex puns and nip slips to
cover up for the fact that the gameplay
is less advanced than your average
iPhone app so if you like playing Simon
you'll love playing Leisure Suit Larry
red green yellow blue yellow yellow
yellow green yellow blue yellow boring
number two Rumble roses xx this is a
women's wrestling game two women enter
sit on each other's faces section boobs
and one is crowned the winner my friends
never actually played this game they
just used it as a lesbian porn simulator
you said you wouldn't tell anybody that
oh sorry dude number one dead or live
beach volleyball this is a really
significant game because it's when DOA
decided that nobody was playing the
games for gameplay and just decided to
show women in bikinis at the beach if
you ever wondered why women hate us well
this is it you'd be frustrated too if
every time you came home your girlfriend
was drooling over a video game featuring
a man with a five-foot penis your
girlfriend plays the video game I'm in
dude not cool you're right it's six feet
you